for black history month the neon museum
highlighting the role that the
short-lived moulin rouge hotel played on
the road to
ending segregation in las vegas the long
gone hotel and casino was the first
major racially integrated hotel back in
the mid-1950s
while our hector mejia is live downtown
with a little bit more but a
great exhibit out there hector
it really is there's a lot of history
here nate good morning to you and here's
that massive mulan rouge sign you can
see it's on
last year the neon museum re-illuminated
the sun which is from 1955 and
if you look closely you'll notice this
some of the old neon was still good so
they kept that and added new neon
that's why you see a mix of sort of
lighter pink and darker pink tones on
the sign
the neon museum is focusing on black
history month they have an exhibit in
the lobby and it showcases artifacts
from moulin rouge
things like dinnerware glassware gaming
chips magazine covers it's here through
august
in partnership with the museum of gaming
history but because it's in the lobby
you don't have to buy a ticket to see
the artifacts
moulin rouge was groundbreaking for
black entertainers back in mid 1950s
las vegas was segregated entertainers
black entertainers could come here and
work on the strip and perform on the
strip but they couldn't stay on the
strip or downtown
so the moulin rouge was the first major
racially integrated hotel
they would go there and it became
immensely popular with
entertainers who would go and do the
third show at 2 30 in the morning
so the rat pack was famous for showing
up and entertaining folks
then in 1960 years after the property
closed governor grant sawyer had a
meeting with
naacp leaders and other leaders from the
historic west side
they all met at the coffee shop inside
the property and they hammered out an
agreement they called
the moulin rouge agreement that led to
the beginning
of the end of segregation in hotels and
casinos in town
and still ahead of the next half hour
we'll go into a little bit more detail
about the artifacts you can see inside
the lobby reporting live this morning
from the neon museum hector mejia
8 news now